[Music]
Mata's in Ohio is it irresponsible to
give away all of your savings in
retirement if you feel strongly that the
Lord is leading you to do so nope
it's not yours it's his and if that's
God and he says give it all away do it
I've got a friend named pastor Robert
Morris who has done that twice in his
life gave away every single thing he
owned house cars no money down to zero
he was basically well I mean he's
homeless in that sense when we rented a
house down to nothing and God has
replenished his wealth in both cases
every time and it's a wonderful and
wonderful story and he's just on what's
the name of the book Kelly I'll look
that up for me right quick I can't think
for some reason I get the book blessing
no it's not yet blessed blessed life no
that's not yet it is the blessed life
yeah that's the story that but that's
the story you ought to read that book
it's a wonderful book on generosity the
blessed life pastor Robert Morris and
he's a good friend and he you know he is
convinced and I would not disagree with
him ever on whether he heard from God
the God told him to do that he would
tell you and he's done it twice I have
never done that but I've never been told
to do that and I would also tell you
that that is not normative meaning it's
unusual for God to request that you give
everything away that's not a normal
thing it doesn't follow a pattern in
Scripture but that but does Holy Spirit
do that sometimes with folks sure sure
I'm open to that and only you know if
you really heard from God but uh you
know in general the Bible says in the
house of the wise our stores of choice
food and oil the Bible says to save
money jesus said don't build a tower
without first counting the cost lest you
get halfway up and you're unable to
finish translation you need a budget a
plan and you would not plan to not be
able to pay your bills that's not called
faith
so it is normative to save money in
Scripture it is Norma the normal course
of events and not normal in a negative
way but the typical course of events in
scripture for those of us that are
Christians being directed by scripture
on how to live our lives it's unvarying
usual for god to request you give
everything away then the typical process
is you live on a budget you save money
you build some investments the things
that we do are not unbiblical on our
fact they are very biblical and you know
have an emergency fund live on less than
you make save for you know purchases so
you don't go into debt avoid debt these
are biblical steps for handling money
and lots of scripture to back all of
that up taking care of your own
household first or you're worse than an
unbeliever God loves a cheerful Giver so
we're generous
you know godly man leaves an inheritance
to his children's children which means
your grandkids have money because you
left them some which means you would
have to by definition to have some a
godly man does that the diligent prosper
if you're completely broke we wouldn't
call that prospering and so there's all
these scriptural examples not of a a
prosperity gospel but of a sowing and
reaping mentality that we live in a
cause-and-effect universe and that's
what is typical in Scripture that you
live your life that way and out of that
money as a part of that plan as a part
of that rhythm of life you're generous
and even outrageously generous and and
that's the tithe as a minimum standard a
baseline and above that crazy generosity
and that's how I live but I've never had
God tell me to give it all away but if I
was really sure it was God I would I
really would because I'm a firm believer
God doesn't just on the 10th he owns the
whole thing the earth is the Lord's and
the fullness thereof and that's where we
start where we stop for those of us that
are people of faith and if you're not a
person of faith obviously God's not
gonna tell you to do that cuz you're not
even talking to him cuz you don't think
he's there so by definition
it's just basic critical thinking skills
at that point hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]